regardez ce classement réalisé par CNN
travel vu qu'on parle avec cuisine du
monde et la France n'arrive qu'en
troisième position derrière l'Italie et
la Chine derrière le trio de tête suit
donc l'Espagne et le Japon les
États-Unis eux sont dixième c'est bien
fait pour la cuisine française c'est
bien fait pour leur gueule et ça leur
fera les pieds
ah non mais je suis furieux contre ce
qu'est devenu la cuisine française
regardez cette photo vous l'avez reconnu
c'est le roi Charles III couronné samedi
et c'est son premier portrait officiel
est plus profanes se sont aussi amusés
des bijoux qui accompagnent ce
couronnement notamment des deux sceptre
que tenaient Charles III sur son trône
l'image a été allègrement détourné
ensuite on a vu le roi à tenir des
assiettes en équilibre on l'a vu jouer
de la batterie on l'a vu jouer du
diabolo ou encore en Jedi avec des
sabres lasers la caresse le carrosse
pardon par la caresse
le carrosse de Sa Majesté arrive à la
veille Westminster hier soir le roi
voulait en mettre plein les yeux au
Britannique avec une chorégraphie de
drones époustouflant et un joyeux
mélange de stars de tous les horizons
[Applaudissements]
par le public et la princesse Charlotte
ces stars ne sont pas bousculés au
portillon mais certaines ont enregistré
un message John Collins Tom Jones pierre
Brosnan Hugh Jackman et son purificateur
d'air mais aussi Winnie l'ourson et Tom
Cruise qui a brûlé du kérosène pour
fêter ça un dernier tweet celui d'un
titre de presse parodique qui salue la
réussite de ce chômeur de 73 ans enfin
trouvé un travail
l'avantage du rocher à fleur d'eau à
marée basse c'est qu'on n'a pas besoin
de faire trop d'efforts pour y monter
et là le top du top c'est la position de
la banane
de pilotes à pilote Votre Majesté vous
pouvez être mon coéquipier à tout moment
une silhouette qui n'est pas passée
inaperçue lors du couronnement de
Charles III
certains spectateurs ont pu apercevoir
une figure troublante passée en
arrière-plan faisant penser à la
faucheuse
si des internautes pensent avoir reconnu
l'allégorie de la mort
d'autres suggèrent que ce serait plutôt
Meghan Markle déguisé certains vont plus
loin et pensent qu'il s'agit du fantôme
de Diana venant récupérer sa couronne il
s'agissait en fait d'un verger un membre
hors clergé de la communauté de l'abbaye
de Westminster mais vraiment impression
très étrange dans ce genre de cérémonie
des spectateurs on est complet
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
incroyable là c'est 15% c'est 15%
incroyable la salle de bain est ouverte
c'est pas ce que j'avais imaginé c'est
sûr que sachant que vraiment on aime
avoir une intimité on en a aucune parce
que ce soit clair net et précis mais
c'est qu'un petit détail ça ne fera que
confirmer notre complicité peut-être
ouais c'est cool grâce à Dieu les
toilettes sont fermées manquerait plus
que ça
va bien le bleu
[Musique]
séduire de mille manières
synchroniser ses gestes pour trouver
l'accord parfait
[Musique]
il faut que tu saches quelque chose
j'ai vu une autre fille aussi
aujourd'hui
et du coup elle s'est déplacée et du
coup j'ai aussi parlé avec elle et le
problème c'est que en fait vous êtes
toutes les deux enfin vous avez toutes
les deux des choses qui me plaît
et en fait
il va bien Fabrice
sur l'autoroute pas sur l'autoroute
puisque c'était une soirée
après le travail d'accord
j'avais un peu trop bu je pense et puis
voilà
tu prends mal tu as dit la même chose ou
pas oui
[Musique]
pendant plusieurs semaines et après n'as
se connaître en toute
[Musique]
mademoiselle a trouvé le mal de sa vie
il formeront un couple uni pour le reste
en de leur jour on s'est rencontré comme
ça dans le couloir par hasard vous êtes
très forte
on a décidé un petit truc
c'est que on allait rester
au château
on va rester mais du coup que toutes les
deux
comment ça va Nicolas
il parle pour sa maman Nicolas qui est à
Castres et les habitants de Castres
Hervé sont les
quatre si j'en crois
le bruit
elles sont 2000 pour témoigner
maintenant tu peux dégager
bonne soirée bonne soirée bonne nuit
[Musique]